new this morning an update to a cbs news
investigation a delaware bankruptcy
court judge has ordered hertz to reveal
data on auto theft reports filed against
its customers the judge ruled after
lawyers for cbs news told the court the
public had a right to see that
information consumer investigative
correspondent anna werner has even more
breaking news on this anna good morning
yeah good morning data so you know uh
dana sorry so you know hertz wanted the
court to keep that information under
seal that is secret from the public cbs
news filed an objection and the judge
ruled against hurts now here's the thing
that data has not yet been unsealed we
should get it soon but late yesterday in
a statement to cbs news hertz itself
revealed how many theft reports it files
against renters saying of the more than
25 million rental transactions in the
u.s each year on average
.014 percent are reported to the
authorities on average
we did the math that's 3500 auto theft
reports filed against hertz customers
each year now the company says these are
very rare situations and it only reports
a car stolen after exhaustive attempts
to reach the customer you may remember
my earlier reporting interviewing people
like regina medo who said she rented a
hertz car in may mito told us she
returned it on time then got an email
saying the company had reported it
stolen here's some of our interview
my doorbell rings and i'm fearful
that it's the cops coming to get me
230 people are claiming in court that
they were falsely arrested for rental
car thefts based on erroneous reports
from hertz we've interviewed some who
were arrested at gunpoint again most of
the data is still under seal such as how
many lawsuits have been filed and the
number of inaccurate police reports we
will come back to you when we get that
information when it's actually released
could be sometime later today dana
all right anna thank you very much the
number i don't know the numbers it just
seems high and nobody wants that on
their record and we appreciate the
information in the update